la parole est à françois commeinhes pour
le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci le 30 juillet au cours d'une
conférence de presse le président
socialiste sortant de la région
languedoc-roussillon
damien alary annonce avoir obtenu du
plus haut sommet de l'état la création
pour son bénéfice personnel d'un poste
de président de région de reggae un
cadeau de matignon pour oublier la
première vice présidente régionale qui
lui était promise mais quand douloureuse
accord électoral entre le ps et le prg a
cédé à l'actuel ministre du logement
dans la foulée kléber mesquida député ps
et président du département de l'hérault
déclare le véhicule législatif et
trouver car automne le parlement doit se
pencher sur la question de la
coordination des territoires c'est
ensuite le premier ministre en personne
en déplacement à vauvert le 11 août qui
officialise cette présidence déléguée
présenter encore comme une création
je cite manuel valls dans le cadre des
grandes régions nous engagerons par la
loi une présidence déléguée pour que
chaque territoire regarde sa force
et d'annoncer lui aussi une loi pour
l'automne hier pourtant à l'assemblée ce
même premier ministre a été contredit
par vous même monsieur le guen qui avait
affirmé que cette présidence déléguée
existait déjà dans la loi en évoquant un
échelon intermédiaire alors permettez
moi d'essayer de comprendre si je
décrypte ces propos s'il s'agit
seulement d'adapter maintenant les
règlements intérieurs pour doter une
vice-présidence de délégation générale
quel rétropédalage le gouvernement
aurait-il entendu la colère des élus et
des citoyens face à la mascarade
estivale de la loi delgal harry ne
pouvons penser comme premier ministre
puisse annoncer publiquement
l'inscription d'un projet de loi pour je
cite encore la création d'une présidence
déléguée sans le mettre en oeuvre
j'en conclus que le gouvernement a donc
bel et bien reculer
quant à mobiliser le parlement pour
voter une loi de complaisance pour un
intérêt particulier le sénat n'aurait pu
accepter cette indécence ma question
sera donc simple monsieur le ministre
alors que vous preniez ici même
l'an passé la rationalisation de la
carte régionale et des dépenses avec une
baisse drastique des dotations pouvez
vous avancer les contours cette
présidence déléguée évoqué hier
assemblée nationale ses compétences son
positionnement au sein de l'exécutif et
les moyens financiers afférents
saura-t-elle par exemple dotées d'un
cabinet alors que le premier nice a été
publiquement contredit hier la faut
conclure par vous-même me confirmez vous
que le gouvernement appelle et bien
reculer qu'il n'y aura pas de loi créant
le poste de présidente de région délégué
contrairement aux déclarations publiques
de monsieur manuel va pour la parole que
monsieur jean marie le guen en charge
des relations avec le parlement monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je vais parler avec des gants
évidemment pour vous répondre en vous
disant que je ne suis pas sûr que tous
nos téléspectateurs et bien compris
l'ensemble de votre question néanmoins
néanmoins je voulais vous remercier
d'avoir cité des éminents élus
représentants des territoires de votre
région qui sont effectivement candidat à
de futures élections et je n'ai pas
compris si vous alliez les soutenir mais
peut-être en tout et à cause que mes
réponses vont vous aider à faire votre
décision en tout cas je voudrais
apporter quelques précisions
effectivement regard des interrogations
qui sont les vôtres
effectivement vous avez raison le
gouvernement dans le débat à propos des
régions à la demande d'un certain nombre
de régions s'étaient interrogés sur la
nécessité de légiférer pour la création
d'un poste de président délégué notre
analyse juridique maintenant est très
claire vous le savez ce n'est pas
nécessaire et cela ressort du droit
actuel tel qu'il existe à tel point
d'ailleurs vous l'avez site est
effectivement en côte d'or
le président sauvadet a mis en place
pour son département
une telle disposition et plus encore
plus près de vous encore le département
de la vienne présidé par monsieur bruno
belin a effectivement décidé de la même
façon de la création d'une présidence
déléguée qui est intermédiaire entre
l'ensemble des vices présente le premier
vice président et le président de la
région
lyon les régions qui le souhaitent et
les régions qui le souhaitent qu'elles
soient ou non issu de la fusion du 1er
janvier 2016 pourront donc également usé
de cette faculté je voulais vous
rassurer monsieur le sénateur cette
souplesse pourrait se révéler tout à
fait nécessaire pour la fusion notamment
de plusieurs régions dans les grandes
régions
cela permettra de faciliter l'insertion
de ces régions de ces territoires dans
en s'assurant que l' équilibre entre les
différents territoires qui composent ces
nouvelles grandes régions sera
préservant alors évidemment et
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire
cette fonction ne présentera aucun
surcoût pour les régions tout d'abord
parce que le vice-président délégué fera
partie de l'ensemble du nombre de vice
présidents
ensuite parce que le président délégué
ne disposera pas de moyens particuliers
supplémentaires et je vous rappelle et
ça devrait être surtout cela qui vous
donnera satisfaction que les treize
grandes régions métropolitaines à
diviser par deux le nombre de vice
présidents et les indemnités versées à
ce titre seront donc aussi divisé par
deux voilà monsieur le sénat il faut
conclure scission et je conclus là
dessus qu'ils vont dans le sens de la
construction de la nouvelle carte de
france des régions que nous avons mis en
oeuvre